some of the Ana's many fans have taken
to creating their own art around around
after so it takes place in Seattle yes
so there we go hence the Space Needle I
like this one as a writer talking about
that tension between doing what your
audience once like is there any tension
between pleasing the audience and
actually like trying to you know get out
what you want to get out is there are
those things in conflict for me there
was a ton of that but it just made it
more entertaining for me they wanted me
especially with the romance love story
they always wanted this happy ending and
they kept saying from the fifth chapter
when are they going to be married when
are they getting married they have to be
married and Tess is 18 so she's not
getting married even though i did but
still she's not going to get married and
so it was a lot of back-and-forth of
like they have an influence on the story
and they own it I feel at least they own
after just as much as I do but I'm not
going to write what they want me to
write because I hadn't done that the
entire time and they loved it so there
was a lot of I can't believe you did
this I'm never reading it again and then
the next chapter they would be like I
had came back I'm sorry so I was like
there was a lot of that tension